[Music]
the vixen has hit the carpet how does it
feel to be here at the finale
it feels so fabulous this is the finish
line and I cannot wait to cross the baby
tell me about this look tonight this is
a softer side of the Vixen Victor has
many soft sides I just keep them tucked
away this is a this is I'm you know
black girl magic is my life and I just
wanted to come out and show some royalty
and some magic you made people feel all
sorts of ways this season really what
was like to process all that reaction
and kind of see the good the bad the
ugly the great yeah I mean it was up I
mean it's pretty predictable I like I've
been myself my whole life so I know how
people are gonna come back this time it
was just a lot more people but it was
all good I'm a tough cookie I'm just
fine
[Music]
if you could go back and do anything
differently would you know because you
wouldn't be so excited to talk to me
right now so no regrets damn it what did
you learn about yourself from this
experience I mean I didn't go on the
show to learn about myself I went on the
show to teach other people about myself
and I think they learned a lot Yankee
Stadium
yeah and it's not easy but I did him so
I'm proud of that
it's all stars for in your future not at
all it was a very good experience it was
on my bucket list and I'm again happy to
cross the finish line tonight yes
absolutely